[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález y
este es el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un recorrido por las
noticias más destacadas relacionadas con
la pandemia de kobe y 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en esta edición
el mundo contabiliza ya más de 3
millones de víctimas mortales por cuenta
de la pandemia de kobe 19 el nuevo
rebrote es particularmente agresivo en
américa latina en donde se registran la
mitad de los casos y en donde circula ya
la variante británica y brasileña junto
con una lenta vacunación veremos cuál es
la situación en esa región en el marco
de la cumbre iberoamericana organizada
por el principado de andorra que tuvo
lugar esta semana los mandatarios
asistentes mostraron su preocupación por
la inequidad en la repartición de las
vacunas el acaparamiento de las mismas
por parte de algunos países así como el
retraso en el mecanismo kóvacs que ha
afectado a los países más pobres y
hablaremos de la situación de colombia
país que vive el pico más agresivo de
contagio desde que comenzó la pandemia a
lo largo de la semana superaron
varias veces de manera continua los 400
fallecidos mientras que las dosis
inoculadas ya llegan a cerca de 4
millones pero la situación hospitalaria
es crítica cerca del 90% de la ocupación
de las ucis en algunas regiones de ese
país comenzamos entonces el programa con
una cifra como ya les decía esta fue la
cifra dada a conocer a lo largo de la
semana y es que el mundo contabilizó
tres millones de fallecidos por cuenta
del joven 19 de hecho para el cierre de
estas semanas ya la cifra llega a los 3
millones 76 mil 400 personas fallecidas
la directora de la organización
panamericana de la salud que ariza en
quien se refirió a esta preocupante
cifra pero también hizo énfasis en la
preocupante situación de américa latina'
ante el repunte de casos en varios
países de la región escuchemos
el fin de semana el mundo alcanzó un
hito trágico más de 3 millones de
personas perdieron la vida por lakovic y
prácticamente la mitad de estas muertes
ocurrieron aquí en las américas en
américa del sur los casos se están
acelerando en colombia venezuela bolivia
y uruguay argentina también tuvo un
crecimiento rápido en el número de
infecciones nuevas y ha asumido
el tercer número más alto
de casos en la región así las cosas
demos un vistazo a las cifras globales
del avance de la pandemia de kobe 19
para el cierre de esta semana fueron
contabilizados 144 millones 979 mil
casos confirmados en el mundo entero la
cifra de fallecidos ya se lo mencionaba
supera los 3 millones 76 mil
los afortunados recuperados ya superan
los 83 millones 339 mil 814 personas
eeuu india brasil francia y rusia son
los 5 países más afectados por la
pandemia a nivel mundial
ahora veamos las cifras pero de nuestra
región de américa latina en donde el
rebrote tiene las cifras en niveles
alarmantes comenzamos en brásil que está
entre los más afectados en el mundo
entero allí hay más de 14 millones 100
mil casos de contagio y más de 383 mil
personas ya han fallecido argentinas
contabilizados millones 796 mil personas
contagiadas 60 mil allí han fallecido
muy de cerca le sigue colombia con 2
millones 720 mil casos y más de 70 mil
víctimas mientras que méxico llega a los
2.3 millones de casos y 214 mil personas
han fallecido cierra este top 5 perú con
1.7 millones de casos de contagio y más
de 58 mil fallecidos al cierre de esta
semana
y eeuu ya ha administrado cerca de 200
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 superando así ampliamente la
meta que tenía el gobierno del
presidente joe biden que esperaba a
inocular a 100 millones de personas en
los primeros 100 días que va a cumplirse
la próxima semana así están las cosas en
este país veámoslo en el siguiente
informe
eeuu el territorio con más muertes
causadas por el hobbit 19 parece empezar
a dejarlo atrás el país donde viven 328
millones de personas logro inocular 200
millones de dosis del fármaco contra el
coronavirus el 26 por ciento de la
población está totalmente vacunada
mientras que otro 40% recibió al menos
una dosis el punto actual de la campaña
que empezó a principios de año ya superó
las expectativas de la propia casa
blanca baiden había prometido alcanzar
esta cifra para sus primeros 100 días de
gobierno que se cumplen el 29 de abril y
no logramos twitter o llegamos a las 200
millones de dosis el 92º el día de mi
mandato
sin embargo el 60% de los trabajadores
activos no está vacunado por lo que el
presidente estadounidense anunció
incentivos económicos a los empresarios
que permitan que sus empleados se
vacunen y recuperen en horas laborales
ningún trabajador estadounidense debería
perder ni un dólar de sueldo por elegir
cumplir con el deber ciudadano de
vacunarse no obstante la administración
de las vacunas no fue equitativa en el
territorio estadounidense especialmente
en áreas rurales donde aún hay
excepticismo al fármaco y para alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño es necesario que
al menos el 70 por ciento de la
población esté vacunada el ritmo de
vacunación también es desigual a escala
global las 200 millones de dosis
inoculadas en eeuu representan un 20 por
ciento de las administradas a nivel
mundial
y el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador fue vacunado esta semana
el mandatario de los mexicanos recibió
la primera dosis de la vacuna
desarrollada por astrazéneca para
estimular la inmunización contra el
coronavirus en su país
lópez obrador fue inoculado ante las
cámaras de televisión y en presencia de
los periodistas que asistieron a su
tradicional rueda de prensa matinal esto
dijo
estamos nosotros seguros de que no hay
ningún riesgo ningún peligro
no hay reacciones graves
que estamos dándole seguimiento
todos los estudios que se están haciendo
en el mundo
para garantizar la seguridad de las
personas ya que hablamos de vacunación
vamos a otra región destacada de nuestro
continente veamos precisamente cómo
avanza la vacunación en la zona del
caribe demos un vistazo a las cifras
allí lidera república dominicana que
cierra esta semana con más de 900.000
dosis inoculadas ya se aproxima al
millón destacamos también a barbados con
71 mil dosis y ahora vemos a trinidad y
tobago en donde la vacunación allí es un
poco más lenta ronda apenas las 16 mil
dosis inoculadas jamaica es el segundo
país con la mayor cantidad de dosis
aplicadas pero las cifras para el cierre
de esta semana todavía no habían sido
actualizadas por parte de la autoridad
sanitaria de ese país para el momento de
el cierre de redacción de este programa
y en el marco de la cumbre
iberoamericana que tuvo lugar esta
semana y que fue organizada por el
principado de andorra uno de los temas
centrales del encuentro giró en torno al
acceso equitativo y universal de las
vacunas dadas las claras diferencias que
hay entre los países que económicamente
han podido acceder masivamente a ellas y
en los que están esperando recibirlas a
través del mecanismo kóvacs los
mandatarios asistentes a este evento
coincidieron en las críticas al retraso
que tiene este mecanismo y al
acaparamiento y también a las demoras en
las entregas
todos los mandatarios que asistieron a
la cumbre iberoamericana coincidieron en
una cosa la reivindicación del acceso
equitativo y universal a la vacuna
contra el jove 19 a pesar de proceder de
distintos espectros políticos los
líderes que participaron en el encuentro
semipresencial rechazaron el acceso
desigual a los fármacos y el retraso del
mecanismo kóvacs además luis arce
presidente de bolivia pidió la
liberación de las patentes las poderosas
transnacionales farmacéuticas que tienen
patentes sobre los diagnósticos
medicamentos y vacunas deben liberarlas
y hacerlas de dominio público o emitir
autorizaciones voluntarias sin costo
para lograr un acceso real de parte de
todas las naciones sin excepción
recordando el carácter global de la
pandemia se apostó por la inmunización
mundial para acabar con el virus
debemos asumir además que nadie está a
salvo hasta que todos estemos a salvo y
por grande tenemos que avanzar hacia una
inmunización en vistas a la situación
españa se comprometió a donar entre un
5% y un 10% de sus inoculantes américa
latina'
por su parte lado ps señaló que los
países ricos poseen hasta cinco veces
más vacunas de las que necesitan y
advirtió sobre el aumento de contagios
en sudamérica
pero en ningún sitio los contagios son
tan preocupantes como en sudamérica
donde los casos se están incrementando
en casi todos los países en américa
latina es actualmente el epicentro de la
pandemia acumula alrededor de 27
millones de contagios y 873 mil muertes
la región centroamericana también se ha
visto seriamente afectada por la nueva
ola de contagios costa rica guatemala y
honduras ven un incremento en el número
de hospitalizaciones mientras que la
vacunación avanza lentamente y otra
parte en panamá y en el salvador el
rebrote parece ser un poco más leve y ha
permitido mantener
cierto ritmo en la inmunización de los
habitantes así está la situación allí
la pandemia de coronavirus se agudiza en
parte de centroamérica de las nuevas
olas de kobe 19 dejan un récord de
pacientes en unidades de cuidados
intensivos en medio de las pocas vacunas
costa rica con 5 millones de habitantes
registra un aumento en los contagios con
más de 233 mil casos positivos y con 277
de las 316 camas de unidades de cuidados
intensivos que existen ocupadas el
gobierno de guatemala declaró alerta
roja en su red hospitalaria a raíz de un
incremento de los casos que tiene
saturados a todos los hospitales del
país con un plan de vacunación lento el
presidente guatemalteco pidió equidad en
el acceso al medicamento guatemala al
igual que todos nuestros países hermanos
ha reforzado sus estrategias nacionales
e internacionales para tener una
respuesta inmediata en la adquisición de
las vacunas para todos los guatemaltecos
pero los esfuerzos resultan infructuosos
porque el acceso a la vacuna sigue
siendo limitado y en honduras las
autoridades sanitarias del sector
público y privado avisaron esta semana
que la tendencia al alza de los
pacientes contagiados
por nuevos confinamientos en el país son
más de 200 2000 personas que han dado
positivo en la prueba de coi 19 si el
panorama se ve tenso en estos países en
la otra mitad de centroamérica la
situación parece ser más estable panamá
registra más de 362.000 casos de
contagios sin embargo las autoridades
sanitarias dicen que la pandemia ha
logrado ser más controlada tras la
segunda ola que sufrieron a finales de
2020 por su parte el gobierno del
salvador afirmó que hay una cierta
estabilidad en el número de contagios
así como un 70 por ciento de
disponibilidad de camas hospitalarias en
el país y en nicaragua las cifras son
bajas con casi 7 mil contagios
registrados sin embargo estos números
son debatidos por una red de médicos
voluntarios que aseguran que el
escenario es mucho más grave ya está ola
de contagios está imparable en colombia
el promedio de fallecidos esta cifra son
alarmantes son 400 personas diarias en
promedio mientras que ciudades como
medellín cali y medellín que es la
segunda ciudad en importancia del país
las llegaron al 100% están próximas a
llegar al 100 por ciento de la ocupación
de las salas de cuidado
así también avanza la vacunación muy
lentamente e incluso ha habido denuncias
de pérdida de algunas dosis en algunas
regiones de ese país hayan la
inoculación de las segundas dosis que
estaban previstas para algunos
ciudadanos vamos a conocer los detalles
de la situación en colombia en la
redacción de france 24 está nuestro
compañero santiago ariztía con más
información hola santiago gracias por
estar con nosotros hoy en el programa y
comencemos por la situación hospitalaria
que es crítica sobre todo ya lo decía en
bogotá y en medellín que son las
ciudades más grandes del país el récord
de fallecidos también es altísimo y las
salas de juego intensivo saturadas
hola santiago bueno este nuevo rebrote o
como lo denominan muchos tercera hora
está golpeando particularmente fuerte a
colombia en el caso de bogotá a la
capital del país se está enfrentando un
significativo aumento de lo que es la
ocupación por kobe 19 de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos que llego al 80 y
8.1 por ciento estamos hablando de una
cifra que por supuesto refleja no lo que
serían las consecuencias que dejaron los
desplazamientos y también las reuniones
familiares que se dieron durante la
semana santa con bogotá acercándose al
90 por ciento de la ocupación de las
ucis no puede ser descartado entonces
que el gobierno local decrete nuevas
restricciones en los próximos días
entretanto algo que cabe destacar y es
que el gobernador encargado del
departamento de antioquia
estamos hablando de luis fernando suárez
indicó que ante la presencia de las
variantes brasileña y también la
británica del coronavirus o anticipo
según sus propias palabras a un medio
nacional que se espera un tsunami de
muertes en el departamento debido a la
ocupación de las ucis que llega al 90
por ciento y también por supuesto por el
número d
de hecho hay que decir que antioquia y
su capital la ciudad de medellín están
liderando la tasa de fallecimientos a
nivel nacional y los médicos han llegado
a enfrentar la difícil tarea de tener
que decir bajo estrictos criterios ya
previamente estipulados por supuesto a
quienes atender a quienes ingresar a las
ucis a quienes trasladar a otras
ciudades del país es recordemos es un
procedimiento conocido como trias ético
y situaciones similares se presentan
también en la ciudad de pereira estamos
hablando de la más poblada de la zona
cafetera colombiana ubicada en el centro
del país y a lo largo de la semana el
promedio diario de fallecidos a nivel
nacional recordemos que fue de 400
muertes hablamos de una cifra
absolutamente récord para este país en
total ya más de 70 mil personas han
perdido la vida desde el inicio de la
emergencia sanitaria y más de 2.7
millones de casos han sido confirmados
con estas cifras el mes de abril se
espera que sea el más mortífero en
colombia hasta el momento santiago
hablamos ahora de la vacunación que está
avanzando lentamente hay denuncias
los ciudadanos de las pérdidas de
algunas dosis algunos ciudadanos tampoco
van a sus citas de vacunación y algunas
personas denuncian que hay escasez de
dosis en algunas regiones qué es lo que
sucede
bueno santiago a la impresión de la
mayoría de los colombianos es que la
vacunación está siendo bastante más
lenta de lo que debería hacer pero según
víctor muñoz él es director del
departamento administrativo de la
presidencia él aseguró que la vacunación
va bien y ya 4 millones de personas han
recibido una o dos dosis y además se
espera que el país reciba a cerca de 549
mil dosis de un lote de la vacuna de
facer y además un millón de dosis de la
vacuna de sinovac que fueron recibidas
este mes de esta manera el gobierno
colombiano está esperando llegar a 5.6
millones de dosis inoculadas para el
próximo 4 de mayo una nueva meta que se
ha puesto el gobierno y sí es cierto que
ha habido denuncias de pérdidas de dosis
porque se corta la cadena de frío como
sucedió por ejemplo en la ciudad de cali
así 162 dosis de la vacuna de facer no
cumplieron con los protocolos de la
cadena de refrigeración y el hecho fue
denunciado por un concejal local pero
también muchas dosis se han perdido
porque los ciudanos no se presentan a
suscitada de vacunas
santiago asimismo algunos ciudadanos
denunciaron a través de las redes
sociales por ejemplo que sus citas para
recibir la segunda dosis fueron
canceladas porque no hay vacunas
suficientes hasta el momento colombia
recordemos ha recibido vacunas de facer
y de sinovac por el mecanismo kóvacs y
tiene además acuerdos de compra con
astrazéneca con modernas y también con
sansón y johnson recordemos que el
objetivo del país es inmunizar al 70% de
los 50 millones de habitantes es decir
35 millones y esto para finales de año
santiago y para darle un poco más de
ritmo a esta vacunación en colombia el
gobierno ha planteado la posibilidad que
el sector privado entre a ofrecer la
vacunación y el escenario allí a nivel
político pues obviamente generó
discrepancias en torno a esa idea
bueno el gobierno colombiano presentó
una resolución que dio origen a lo que
es el decreto 507 y que es el que le
permite a entidades privadas adquirir
vacunas contra el cob y 19 para
distribuirlas a lo largo y ancho de todo
el país y de manera gratuita y sin
derecho a la comercialización y de esta
manera por supuesto poder acelerar lo
que es el plan de vacunación
este decreto generó todo tipo de
opiniones por supuesto entre los
ciudadanos en el sector político y
también entre los empresarios del país
pero también entre las farmacéuticas
puntualmente la firma fisher y bryant ex
anunció que no venderá a vacunas a
privados dado que su prioridad es
cumplir con los acuerdos de suministro
firmados con gobiernos con
organizaciones supranacionales y también
con el mecanismo kóvacs recordemos
además que desde china la farmacéutica
sinovac indicó que tampoco le va a
vender a privados colombianos y dijeron
que solo cooperarán con el gobierno
recordemos además que la vacuna de
sinovac es la de mayor distribución en
toda américa latina ante la negativa de
esas dos farmacéuticas tal parece que
colombia está negociando con
para que la vacuna sea distribuida a
través de privados allí en este país
algo que está todavía en estudio y de
negociación hablemos ahora del gobierno
qué medidas ha tomado aparentemente
enviar al confinamiento le genera un
poco de temor al gobierno por cerrar la
parte comercial que ya ha tenido
suficientes pérdidas a lo largo del año
ya ha habido incluso protestas y
manifestaciones por parte de los
comerciantes y otros sectores que ven en
los confinamientos como un riesgo para
sus negocios
y el panorama en colombia ha llevado a
que múltiples ciudades y regiones del
país hayan tenido que mantener la media
de toque de queda nocturno y también
regresaron al confinamiento estricto
durante los fines de semana la decisión
claramente ha sido rechazada por el
sector de los comerciantes también por
los trabajadores de la gastronomía y de
la hotelería que realizaron marchas y
protestas en diferentes ciudades del
país y esto para rechazar los cierres
durante los fines de semana las
autoridades aseguran que medidas de este
tipo como los confinamientos durante los
fines de semana los toques de queda o el
denominado pico y se dura una medida que
permite a los ciudadanos hacer las
compras básicas de acuerdo al último
número de su identificación ciudadana
son necesarias dicen las autoridades
para hacer frente al pico de contagios
que se espera tome una semana más para
comenzar a dar muestras concretas de
reducción
santiago pues muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la redacción de
france 24 allí en bogotá poniéndonos al
tanto de la situación en colombia le
consultamos al doctor carlos eduardo
pérez infectólogo y asesor científico de
france 24 ustedes
sobre las razones que ha llevado a que
este pico de contagio esté teniendo un
mayor impacto en el número de casos y de
fallecidos pese a que están avanzando
también los planes de vacunación y que
las personas ya aparentemente deberían
de tener claros los protocolos de
bioseguridad y de distanciamiento esta
fue su explicación responde en gran
parte también a la presencia de unos
linajes virales como este linaje de
manaos que es un linaje que se ha estado
extendiendo paulatinamente en brasil es
altamente circulante pérdida se ha
detectado en todos los países y
probablemente se explique la aceleración
de los casos además de otros
determinantes sociales es decir que por
ahora en los linajes virales que se
están volviendo preguntas en la región
explica en esa celebración de casos y
nos vamos ahora está ecuador allí
también el rápido aumento de los casos y
los contagios y también los fallecidos
ha llevado a que se ha instaurado
nuevamente el confinamiento general en
todo el país ecuador registra más de 365
mil casos y unas 17.000 personas ya han
fallecido el gobierno de ecuador
no quiere revivir esas terribles
imágenes de los cuerpos abandonados en
las calles de la ciudad de guayaquil que
le dieron la vuelta al mundo al inicio
de la pandemia y por eso toma medidas
adicionales vamos a conocer de cuales se
trata está con nosotros gustavo ortega
el corresponsal de france 24 en la
ciudad de quito de gustavo gracias por
acompañarnos hoy comencemos entonces por
el restablecimiento de la medida de
confinamiento que entra en vigor a
partir del viernes en ecuador
bueno ecuador declaró el cuarto estado
de sección focalizado ante el incremento
acelerado de contagios y el 99 por
ciento de ocupación hospitalaria en todo
el país a causa del cómic 19 la medida
regirá durante 28 días y se aplicará
desde el viernes 23 de abril hasta el 20
de mayo en 16 provincias del país desde
este viernes a partir de las 20 horas
hasta el día lunes a las 5 de la mañana
regirá el confinamiento absoluto y los
ecuatorianos deberán permanecer ciencia
y de sus casas durante los fines de
semana mientras que de lunes a viernes
sólo se permitirá la movilidad desde las
5 de la mañana hasta las 8 de la noche
aplicando toques de queda los cuerpos de
seguridad podrán ingresar a los hogares
que hagan fiestas clandestinas una de
las principales violaciones de las
restricciones el transporte público
también se suspende durante los fines de
semana y sólo podrán circular los taxis
identificados durante el horario de
toque de cgera se mantendrán operativos
los servicios básicos personal
estratégico de los aeropuertos puertos y
puestos fronterizos la medida de
generador rechazo por parte del sector
comercial trabajadores que dependen
también del ingreso diario porque se
cerrarán comercios y se afectará la
economía sólo se permitirá abrir los
comercios
con servicio domicilio y sectores
estratégicos entre otros la vacunación
no se detendrá y se respetarán las citas
médicas pero la medida también ha
generado las visitas masivas al
supermercado y generado nerviosismo ante
el inicio de estos confinamientos
absolutos gustavo y otra de las medidas
excepcionales que ha instaurado el
gobierno del ecuador es la ley de manejo
de emergencias sanitarias en qué
consiste esta medida
bueno en medio de la pandemia la falta
de regulaciones legales para controlar
el estado actual el gobierno ecuatoriano
presentó ante la asamblea nacional una
ley orgánica para la gestión de la
emergencia sanitaria por la pandemia un
documento que según han dicho busca
establecer las regulaciones legales
restricciones derecho de libertad
tránsito entre otras y de igual forma en
caso una emergencia sanitaria por
pandemia como está sucedido en este
momento se pretende regular las
potestades de los organismos públicos y
las sanciones por incumplimiento de las
restricciones se clasifican también las
zonas de alerta sanitaria y los niveles
de alerta el alcance la temporalidad de
los niveles de emergencia también
declarado en espacios geográficos
específicos también se establecen
regulaciones especiales en la red de
salud pública
de igual forma si éstas superarán la
demanda hospitalaria tales como está
sucediendo en este momento donde no
existen camas en los hospitales y más de
300 personas esperan una cama en
cuidados intensivos en todo el país y
finalmente la gestión de los recursos e
instalaciones en caso de emergencia por
la pandemia está presente también esta
propuesta normativa el manejo adecuado
de cadáveres disposiciones sanitarias
restricciones de movilidad prohibiciones
el control de brotes por contagio para
asistir así también a la población
afectada también se contempla en esta
normativa legal presentada ante la
asamblea nacional una ley que todavía
tiene que ser aprobada por el parlamento
en ecuador cambiamos de tema gustavo
aprovechó para preguntarle por la
vacunación cómo está avanzando allí en
ecuador que es clave para mitigar el
impacto de la pandemia
bueno en un momento donde ya no existen
camas en el sistema público ni en el
privado la principal queja es el cobro
de garantías para acceder a la atención
médica en algunos casos hasta cinco mil
dólares diarios o garantías de diez mil
hasta cuarenta mil dólares para acceder
a una cama en el servicio privado de
salud otra que es ha sido el alto costo
de las pruebas rápidas de 19 en muchos
casos oscilan entre 60 y 120 dólares
para acceder a una de ellas en un país
donde más de un millón de personas han
perdido el empleo y muchos sobreviven
con tres dólares diarios alcanzar una
prueba pcr se hace casi que imposible
por ello el ejecutivo nacional también
emitió una regulación donde las pruebas
no pueden superar los 45 dólares un
precio que no deja de ser elevado para
una familia promedio de cuatro personas
por ejemplo en este sentido color
también intenta levantar su sistema de
vacunación que avanza de forma muy lenta
o un porcentaje vacunación de 2 por
ciento de la población luego de seis
ministros en asumir el cargo de medio de
la pandemia el titular de salud intenta
superar los obstáculos para concluir con
los adultos mayores según el ejecutivo
nacional en ecuador se han vacunado un
poco más de 457 mil personas en las
primeras dosis y el reto será concluir
con la fase
un nuevo personal estratégico y adultos
mayores para comenzar así con la
vacunación masiva de personas el reto se
mantiene no sólo en ecuador sino en toda
la región gustavo muchas gracias por
este reporte desde la ciudad de quito y
esta semana argentina de la noticia en
la región de américa latina al dar a
conocer que comenzó la producción local
de la vacuna sputnik be desarrollada en
rusia la empresa farmacéutica
laboratorios richmond se produjo ya el
primer lote de esta vacuna rusa contra
el cubil 19 el cual será enviado a moscú
la capital rusa para que el instituto
gamal ella que fue el encargado de su
investigación y desarrollo realice un
control de calidad se espera que la
producción a gran escala comience a
partir del mes de junio lo que
convertiría a argentina en la primera
nación suramericana en producir esta
vacuna rusa
y vamos a profundizar en este y otros
temas de la actualidad de argentina
relacionados con la pandemia por
supuesto está con nosotros natalio con
soy corresponsal de france 24 en buenos
aires
hola natalio y pues comencemos por hacer
un balance de la situación en argentina
que está experimentando también como
muchos otros países un incremento
considerable de los casos de contagio y
también el sistema de salud ya está
mostrando síntomas de saturación
mientras avanza la campaña de vacunación
en la que ya se ha logrado inocular al
menos con una dosis más del 70 por
ciento de los mayores de 70 años pero
todavía falta mucho para poder inocular
al resto de la población hay mucha
preocupación porque argentina hay un
momento muy difícil de la pandemia de 19
con días de números récord de muertes y
con días con casos muy muy altos de
contagio de coronavirus los más altos
desde el inicio de la pandemia más altos
que en esa primera ola de 2020 con una
preocupación muy grande en el sistema de
salud cuando uno habla con gente que
trabaja en unidades de terapia intensiva
están preocupados por la alta ocupación
de camas también porque mucha de la
población que tienen internada es más
joven que la que se veía en el año 2020
y hay ocasiones en que cuesta conseguir
lugar cuesta conseguir camas para
algunas personas que las necesitan si
este tipo de situaciones comienzan a
volverse masivas existe entonces la
preocupación de que el sistema en
argentina se vea
saturado y eso sería muy grave y muy
serio para el país situación similar ya
lo vemos en otros países como colombia y
brasil ya lo mencionábamos natalio pero
quiero profundizar en el tema de la
fabricación de la vacuna sputnik en
territorio argentino que más se sabe al
respecto
si el laboratorio richmond de argentina
que tiene un acuerdo para producir la
vacuna sputnik bay ya logró producir
21.000 dosis de los componentes 1 y 2 a
ser el formulado el envasado los ha
enviado los está enviando a rusia para
que sean verificados para que el
laboratorio que desarrolló esta vacuna
el laboratorio gamal ella haga el
control de calidad necesario una vez
pasado ese proceso la idea es que
empiece la producción con esta primera
etapa de formulado de filtrado de
llenado para posterior distribución la
idea es que el laboratorio poco a poco
pueda ir incorporando más y más etapas
de la producción hasta hacer la
totalidad también para eso están
construyendo quieren construir una nueva
planta más grande su expectativa es
poder producir primero un millón de
vacunas luego escalarlo a cinco millones
y algunas versiones que sugieren que
podrían empezar la producción en junio
eso no está del todo claro hay que ver
si es así también la idea es que
empiecen produciendo para argentina y
luego puedan empezar a también
distribuir
esto de américa latina en cualquier caso
sería el primer laboratorio es el primer
laboratorio en américa latina en
producir la vacuna pues me sube esta
producción en argentina ayudaría mucho
no sólo argentina sino a varios países
de la región para acelerar el proceso de
inmunización me llamó la atención
natalio a lo largo de esta semana que un
grupo de políticos argentinos dijo que
estaba dispuesto o que estaban
dispuestos a donar su salario para que
las autoridades locales pudieran comprar
más instrumentación médica y utensilios
necesarios para poder atender a los
pacientes que están llegando allí
infectados con kobe el 19
bueno la noticia más reciente de la
ciudad de córdoba en el centro del país
de la capital de la provincia del mismo
nombre donde los legisladores donaron un
30% de su sueldo para asistir en la
pandemia y eso se destinó a adquirir
equipamiento médico necesario pero no es
la única noticia de su tipo en lo que va
de la pandemia son 8 las provincias
además de la ciudad de buenos aires
donde los ejecutivos del lugar
decidieron los ejecutivos provinciales
decidieron donar parte del salario o
salarios completos o recortar parte del
salario de algunos cargos más altos de
la administración a veces por varios
meses a veces por algunos meses con
plazos diferentes para tratar de asistir
o contener las necesidades de gastos de
la pandemia se ha replicado también en
algunos municipios y también en
legislativos como mencionábamos en el
caso de córdoba algunos señalan que el
impacto real de este tipo de medidas es
relativo pero otros
sugieren y señalan que en definitiva
también se trata de un gesto simbólico
que ayuda a acompañar los pesares de la
población en general a lo largo de esta
situación de pandemia que también tiene
un impacto fuerte en los bolsillos de la
población de todas maneras natalio no
deja de ser una iniciativa interesante
gracias natalio por este reporte desde
la ciudad de buenos aires y en nuestra
sección en redes veamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa comencemos con
noticias relacionadas con el deporte
japón declara el estado de emergencia
por tercera vez a menos de 100 días del
inicio de los juegos olímpicos el
aumento de casos llevó a tomar esta
medida pero aún así la presidenta del
comité organizador indicó que no plantea
cancelar las justas en medio de este
tercer estado de emergencia en ese país
aún así se mantiene la incertidumbre
entre deportistas y también entre las
delegaciones lado ms reflexiona sobre la
próxima etapa de investigación del
origen del coronavirus esto después de
que la misión internacional enviada a
china para determinar el origen del
coronavirus dejó más preguntas que
respuestas por este motivo la un
evalúa diferentes maneras para avanzar
en su investigación en medio de los
traspiés diplomáticos y sin generar
muchos choques con el gobierno chino la
umh se indicó que es necesario conocer
el origen su comienzo y la propagación
del virus para evitar un escenario
similar en el futuro con otros posibles
virus y seguimos en otra noticia de
france 24 punto com de nuestra compañera
daniela blandón de la sección de
economía guatemala honduras y el
salvador el hambre se cuadruplicó en un
año de pandemia cerca de 8 millones de
personas están en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria según datos del
programa mundial de alimentos de la
organización de las naciones unidas cuyo
director afirmó que de seguir esta
tendencia eso impulsaría a miles de
personas a dirigirse a la frontera con
eeuu para buscar mejores condiciones de
vida
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana con más noticias el
resumen noticioso de los hechos
destacados de la semana sigan cuidándose
el coronavirus sigan con nuestra
programación hasta entonces
[Música]